[Music]
tonight we have Christopher O'Brien who
is here from Stanford he is visiting
with the casbahs program and he has been
doing really interesting work in getting
people to change their long-term
behavior based on some new techniques
that he's going to be telling us about
tonight and with that I welcome
Christopher thank you all right thank
you sander by the way it's amazing what
it does your confidence when people ask
you if you want to have a cocktail
waiting for you when you get up
so I'm a psychologist I'm a social
psychologist and I study persuasion and
influence and with a goal of identifying
ways to get people to change their
behavior in ways that will be helpful
for addressing some of the very serious
social and policy challenges that
humanity is facing the science are the
the science of behavior change has
become an increasingly important
frontier in the human quest to improve
our health and well-being throughout
much of human history but especially the
20th century we basically could count on
getting rescued by technology right so
anytime we had some serious problem it
was only a matter of time before a pill
or machine or device was invented that
essentially fixed that problem we're
moving out of that space and the reason
for that is many of the most serious
threats to human health and well-being
these days are the result of our own
behavior choices and so we need ways to
get people to change their behavior on a
large scale and it turns out the science
of behavior change is not currently up
to the task it's badly underdeveloped
and so I've been trying to work on this
for I guess now a little over 10 years
and the framing of the problem that I've
I've focused on for at least the last
I'd say five years is basically boils
down to this question how can we create
internalized lasting motivation for
every day should behaviors these are the
things people know they should be doing
but just struggle to muster the
motivation to do on a regular basis
these images give you examples of the
many such behaviors right save for the
future donate to charity read to your
kids if you're a parent eat healthfully
take care of the environment vote don't
text while you're driving that sort of
thing and they also represent by the way
many of the pretty serious and
persistance so if
policy challenges that could be improved
pretty dramatically if we could find
scalable ways scalable and and low
enough cost that we could afford to
scale them to get people to change their
behavior
now I'm not obviously close to the first
person to realize that we need to get
people to change their behavior these
are some of the are just a couple of the
huge number of examples of appeals
people see every day to change their
behavior you can you exercise is
medicine you can beat diabetes by eating
a healthy diet we can save the
environment by turning off the lights
one thing I want you to notice the main
thing I want you to notice about these
is that these are all pragmatic appeals
right they focus on the self-interested
or otherwise pragmatic reason why people
should change their behavior and the
problem with that is that's telling the
reader why the person who made the
appeal thinks it's important or probably
more accurately the person who
commissioned commissioned the appeal but
the problem with that is that it relies
on self-control or willpower to get
people to change their behavior and
psychologists have known for some time
this is not a you want to be relying on
right self-control and willpower works
sometimes in acute situations it does
not work for sustained behavior change
and so I've been thinking a little bit
about how to sort of focus this question
even even more and and and the the sort
of focus version the question that I've
been focusing on is how can we get
people to care about the things they
don't already care about but should a
couple of things I want you to sort of
keep in mind about should behaviors one
is this doesn't represent the situation
people know what the responsible choice
is they're not they're not in doubt
about that right and so telling them or
reminding them of the pragmatic reasons
why they should change their behavior is
unlikely to be giving them new
information so it's not really clear
even what the theory of change is behind
a pragmatic appeal other things that are
sort of a little less sort of directly
obvious are our problems like myopia or
intertemporal discounting it's referred
to in varying ways depending on whether
you're talking to a psychologist or an
economist but the central idea there is
that we over value the immediate present
and undervalue the distant future and so
as with many should behaviors when a
behavior requires a sacrifice in the
immediate term in service of some
distant pragmatic goal the distant
pragmatic goal is unlikely to win that
fight relatedly but distinct is the
notion of procrastination which is
simply even if I do care about that
distant pragmatic goal there's rarely a
compelling reason for me to start
changing my behavior today rather than
tomorrow right and both of these pose
very serious challenges to Tibbett to
getting people to engage in should
behaviors and then the third important
thing to remember I guess it's the
fourth important thing I want to make
top of mind for you is that positive
impact for many of these behaviors
depends on sustain repeated change in
behavior and that's really important
because there's been a major and and
important movement in behavior change
recently called called nudge and most
people refer to it as nudge and it's the
idea that you can you can set up choice
environments so that the easiest thing
to do is the thing that's in most
people's best interest and it's a huge
innovation I think it's it's probably
the single most important innovation and
B in the science of behavior change I
don't know maybe ever it's a hugely
important innovation but the problem the
weakness of it is that it's not very
well suited to the sorts of should
behaviors that require sustained change
across a wide range of context for the
simple reason that we don't have control
over enough of the context in which
people are making decisions right if
you're trying to get people to adopt
healthy diets you might be able to
change the order of the menu items at a
restaurant but that's not going to
transform very many people's lives
because most
at one restaurant all the time and so
the sort of complementary idea to nudge
that I've been working on with my
collaborators is something I'm calling
values alignment and the idea is to
identify existing strongly held and
widely shared values that the desired
behavior might serve and then frame
Appeals for that behavior in terms of
how they might serve this alternative
value and so the idea is you're changing
how people think about the reason for
engaging in should behaviors it's it
becomes less about the distant pragmatic
outcome you're you're pursuing and more
about living in accordance with some
value that is important to you in the
immediate term and and so the idea here
sort of from a theoretical perspective I
talked about intertemporal discounting
this problem that the distant pragmatic
outcome just isn't a strong enough
motivator for people the idea of values
alignment is that you replace that
distant pragmatic outcome with an
immediate symbolic outcomes the good
feeling of knowing you're being the kind
of person you know you feel you should
be being and when I say values I really
do mean values broadly construed right
what a person thinks is important in
life what has immediate motivational
force and so for a lot of the time I
have left I want to talk about a
particular example of a values aligned
appeal that I tested with middle
schoolers the goal was to get eighth
graders to reject unhealthy junk food in
favor of fruit and healthy food and you
know I'll just tell you a bunch of
things you already know just so that
we're all on the same page but personal
dietary choices are an extraordinarily
important cause in fact they're the
single biggest cause of lost years of
healthy life in the developed world and
they're a really strong competitor for
the single biggest cause in the
developing world - they're five times
the unhealthy dietary choices are five
times as important as physical
inactivity as a driver of premature
death and disease
and so for that reason and they're the
major thing behind this skyrocketing
rate of global obesity this is in the US
but the rate the global rate is the
curve looks pretty similar and for this
reason cost-effective scaleable
interventions to get people to change
their health their dietary choices are a
very important scientific priority they
have been for about thirty years and and
by the way the changes don't have to be
big to be very important so for example
there was an estimate published in The
Lancet in 2011 that as of 2011 as little
as a 20 calorie per person reduction on
average across the US and UK would have
gotten those countries to 19 low 1990s
levels of obesity within three years
it's a tiny tiny change but it's got to
be on a massive scale and it's got to be
sustained and so because it's been this
scientific priority there have been lots
of people who've tried to develop
interventions to get people to change
their dietary habits they tend to focus
on the classroom partly because you want
large scale change and schools are one
of the rare opportunities to get access
to basically the entire population at a
at a given age and so one thing that
these interventions basically all have
in common is that they involve some
combination of health and nutrition
education so what's good for you what's
bad for you how do you read the
nutrition labels and what's called
skills training and that usually
involves a combination of learning how
to set realistic goals and analyzing
barriers to behavior change that sort of
thing the other big thing they all have
in common is that they've failed right
so people of been trying to do this for
like 30 years I'm not aware of a single
intervention that keeps affecting
people's behavior after you stop
intervening and I think the major reason
for this is that they all share either
implicitly or explicitly an underlying
assumption and that is that long term
self-interest the desire to be healthy
in the distant future is an effective
motivator for teenagers and I mean I
don't need citations but I have them but
like obviously that's not the case
and so our approach has been to rather
than trying to get adolescents to care
about things they don't care about
reframe the meaning of healthy eating so
that it's consistent with the things
they do care about we focus on three
major values in particular one is the
the sort of well-known teen drive to
rebel against adult Authority
adolescents hate doing what adults tell
them to do they'll often do the opposite
just to reassert their autonomy less
widely appreciated is adolescence is a
period where there's a real increase in
concern for fairness and justice and
beyond the self aims just for to give
you a couple quick examples this is the
time in life when people often first
decide to become vegetarians for moral
reasons or anti-globalization activists
they have a sense of themselves as
agents in the world for the first time
and they want to make the world a better
place and unlike most adults they're not
yet jaded about their prospects for
doing that yeah this collection of
optimistic people was the wrong place to
make that cynical joke okay and then the
third that the third big value is is
gonna be familiar again that's the drive
for peer approval and status it's
certainly not unique to adolescents but
it actually is is very strongly
heightened in adolescence and a big
reason for that is is that the central
task developmental tasks of adolescence
is figuring out how to be social agent
so if you're going to do that you need
to be very attentive to what's being
approved of and what's not and so what
we did to try to appeal to these three
values was essentially it took a
two-fold approach the first is we framed
the entire intervention as an expose of
manipulative food industry marketing
practices aimed at tricking people into
eating more junk food than they would
naturally be inclined to eat and here
I'm talking about things like using
deceptive labeling to conceal the sugar
content in food or spending unbelievable
sums of money on laboratories that are
specifically designed to figure out how
you can formulate foods to make them as
addictive as possible
the second thing we did was emphasize
the social justice consequences of this
food marketing and here unpacking in
particular about
proportionately targeting very young
children poor people and minorities with
marketing of the unhealthiest foods
because they're easy targets and so our
goal here was to frame healthy eating as
a way to stick it to the man to rebell
against controlling adult authority
figure who's trying to control us and as
a way to stand up for people who are
less able to defend themselves both of
which are were sort of deliberately
crafted to appeal to the to this sort of
adolescent set of values and
sensibilities and so essentially what we
what we were aiming to do here was to
replace what we imagined adolescents
sort of default construed their default
understanding of what a healthy eater is
something like healthy eaters are lame
nerds who do what adults tell them to do
with an alternative construal healthy
eaters are independent minded people who
are fighting to make the world a fairer
place that might sound like a tall order
I'll tell you how we tried to do it so
and what I'm going to describe is a a a
pair of randomized controlled trials the
first one was run with the entire eighth
grade class of a rural suburban rural
Texas middle school two years in a row
they were randomly assigned to read one
of three informational articles so
either they read an expose article of
this sort I've already briefly mentioned
an active placebo article so that was
meant to represent the current gold
standard in health education so I took
material straight out of middle school
health class textbooks and
choosemyplate.gov the federal
government's healthy eating website and
then a third condition a note we call in
no treatment control they read an
article but it had nothing to do with
food and then we measured whether this
changed how adolescents were construing
the meaning of healthy eating so whether
they saw it as a yeah as having
different significance than if they got
one of the controls and then we measured
their diet their dietary choices so this
is just sort of a brief schematic to
represent our theory of change here the
idea is to change how adolescents
construe
the meaning of healthy eating so they
would see it as consistent with the
adolescent values of autonomy and social
justice as a result to get them to see
this as a path to peer approval if I'm
acting consistently with widely shared
teen values and I'm being the right kind
of teenager that that my peers should
approve of and as a result of that to
get kids to make healthy choices okay
this is a brief excerpt from our expose
article the title was food in America
the true story what food companies do
behind our backs and how teens can take
a stand to make the world a better place
we told them companies spend billions
trying to get people to eat more than
they really want and they get get rich
doing this and they deliberately target
people have the least ability to defend
themselves people like very young
children and poor people and minorities
we underscored that with this these
kid-friendly marketing characters we
made a point of including images of real
food industry executives all not
coincidentally middle-aged white guys in
suits to serve as the objects of teen
rebellion
okay compare that with our active
placebo control so as I said this was
lifted straight out of middle school
health class textbooks and
choosemyplate.gov
it taught them how the body absorbs
nutrients how to read nutrition labels
that included colorful appealing
pictures of healthy food and specific
recommendations for how to get a
balanced diet okay back to this theory
of change I'm going to tell you a little
bit about what we found so first did we
successfully change adolescents constru
of healthy eating get them to see it as
consistent with the adolescent values of
autonomy and social justice we measured
this by asking them how much they agreed
with statements like eating healthy as a
way to stand up to people who are trying
to control us and when I eat healthy I'm
doing my part to protect kids who are
being controlled by food companies and
we found that having read the expose
article significantly and substantially
increase the extent to which kids agreed
with statements like that relative to
having read one of the to control
articles next did we change their
perceive the perceived social status
appeal of healthy eating so you have to
be a little bit more indirect in trying
to
test that you can't say do you think
that other teenagers will think you're
cool if you do this because teenagers
are very sensitive to the possibility
that they might be being posers so you
have to ask questions like how much do
you agree with this I respect healthy
eaters more than unhealthy eaters right
so that's on the logic that if they say
they respect them more they also expect
that their peers will respect them more
we find that also is significantly
increased by reading the expose article
relative to one of the controls and now
we're down to healthy choices and so in
the first study we ran this this study
I'm talking about right now we looked at
just their food choice the very next day
and the way we were able to measure that
was with the help of a just a really
cooperative principle and so it turns
out he gives the kids junk junk food or
snack pack is what he gives them toward
the end of the the year as a thank you
for their hard work in preparing for
state tests and so he said you guys can
just organize that so we did so we made
up this order form that got distributed
in in homeroom class the day after we
came we made sure that the kids wouldn't
see it as related to our study by having
the principal advertise it long before
anyone knew we were coming so it didn't
it wasn't suddenly this new thing where
they had to choose healthy or unhealthy
food and they got to choose to snack
choices and one drink choice and they
had three healthy snack choices fruit
trail mix or baby carrots and three
unhealthy options Hot Cheetos Doritos
and Oreos and then they had two healthy
drink choices either write a regular
bottled water or sparkling bottled water
or three unhealthy options
sodas two sodas and a high C fruit drink
what we found was that getting the
expose article of the day before
significantly reduced the number of
unhealthy options kids chose but by a
very small margin so 7% reduction in the
number in the average number of
unhealthy choices and so one question is
should we care like a 7% reduction
that's that's really small and so we we
did a little bit of research and we were
able to figure out that just based on
the on the carbohydrate the nutritional
content
of these items this reduction if it were
sustained would actually translate it
into a pound of body fat either not
gained or lost every six weeks for girls
every eight week for eight weeks for
boys opposite I'm pretty sure six weeks
for boys eight weeks for girls bait just
based on what their average calorie
consumption and so good okay we did
successfully change people's healthy
choices that was a gigantic if I just
put out there if it were sustained over
time right I just finished telling you
no one has ever successfully changed
people's dietary habits over time and so
one big reason to think that we couldn't
do this is that kids live in this
environment that is absolutely pervaded
by by junk food marketing it's
deliberately designed to create positive
emotional associations with junk food
and increase consumption it's been shown
to be very successful at doing those
things and and never mind that we need
to overcome that in the first place once
they leave our intervention they go back
into that world right and like just to
give you a little bit of a sense of the
scale here I looked this up so our
budget for this Center for the whole
intervention including evaluation
everything was one hundred thousandth of
1% of Coca Cola's marketing our
advertising budget and so but we had a
thought about how we could try to flip
that on its head and so we ran a second
a second study so again entire class in
in this same Middle School in Texas that
we found that was willing to let us do
studies and we were grateful for that
this time we we eliminated the no
treatment control because it never
differed from the placebo so basically
the placebo really is just that the
current gold standard does nothing I
think is the conclusion we can draw from
that
and so we we randomly assign them to one
or the other of those conditions and
then we measured all the same stuff we
measure the first time we added a couple
of things one was we measured their
immediate gut-level
implicit affective associations with
junk food right this is what junk food
marketing is directly targeting is
trying to create that warm feeling when
you when you see junk food so we
measured that and then we were also able
to get access to data on kids cafeteria
purchases for the entire school year so
now we can look at dietary choices for
overall over a longer period ok I told
you we had an idea for how to flip this
this funding imbalance on its head and
the idea was what if we could change
kids understanding of food ads what if
we could change the effect it had on
them how they understood the meaning of
it so that instead of having this
reaction those ads served as reminders
of our message right every time they saw
food ad they thought of our message and
so if we could do that then we thought
we would be effectively setting up the
situation where the food industry would
be paying to undermine itself with these
kids and so the way we try to do that
with was with an activity we called make
it true so we gave kids these iPads to
work on they had images of food ads and
they were loaded into a software program
that you could write or draw in and we
told the kids you can cross things out
write things in draw whatever you want
take this from a lie and make it true
now when you give teenagers an
assignment that requires they do
something that feels a little bit
subversive this was deliberately meant
to evoke this sort of rebellious notion
of using vandalism right you really
unleash their creativity and so they
came up with some good things right so
Doritos are localized on the inside lies
on the outside Drake is saying I do not
actually like it there
[Laughter]
now you can add diabetes to diabetes
don't eat it will make make your own
choices that's the part I like about
that one and then the thing you want
when you order salad should be salad
okay these are eighth graders okay then
we use this reaction time based computer
task to measure what I was talking about
a minute ago these these immediate gut
level reactions you have there on an
implicit level there beyond our control
and it's just do you have a good feeling
when you see this or a bad feeling when
you see this and we used the this task
which is called the effect
misattribution procedure and what it
involves is just a really quick display
oh that's right this one will work a
really quick display of the image you
actually care about what people think of
then quickly replace by a blank screen
then an unfamiliar character that should
have no emotional association with it
and then this mask and then they're
asked is this Pleasant or unpleasant
relative to other similar unfamiliar
characters and what did you you can even
tell them don't let that initial thing
you saw contaminate your assessment of
that of that neutral character it's
impossible to not let it affect your
your assessment and so and so what you
end up with is is a good is a good
measure of their implicit affective
association with that first thing in
this case the coke-bottle and we did
this with junk food images and we did it
with healthy food images and what we
found was that getting this expose
treatment significantly reduce the
positive association with junk food
significantly increase the positive
association with healthy food and that
change lasted the rest of the school
year we had three months left in the
school year after after getting this
intervention that change held up for as
long as we could keep measuring it but
then the big thing of course is did it
change what kids bought at the cafeteria
so it turns out the the best thing you
can look at in cafeteria data if you
want to know whether people are making
your healthy choices are snacks and
drinks entrees are accounted for all
under the same category so you can't
tell the healthy from the unhealthy like
90% of them are unhealthy but you can't
say for sure snacks and drinks they just
account for separately so you can say
for sure and what we found was a
significant reduction in unhealthy
purchases day to day for the remaining
three years of the of the school year
significant increase in healthy
purchases but this this was actually
qualified by a surprising moderator and
that and that was gender so turns out
this intervention was extraordinarily
successful with teenage boys it wasn't
as effective with teenage girls now all
right I think there are two reasons for
this I don't think it's true that it's
actually not effective I think what you
have to remember is that our control
condition here was the the current gold
standard right the current gold standard
teaches about health and it talks about
calories which evokes concerns about
body image and so I think the more
likely interpretation although we really
need more research to say with with
confidence I think the more likely
interpretation is that this expose
intervention is roughly as effective as
this the traditional approach with girls
but - the body shaming that's conjecture
we know for sure that it was very
successful in changing boys habits the
in fact it created a 31% reduction in
junk food purchases a hundred and sixty
percent increase in healthy purchases
don't get too excited about 160 percent
it's on a very small base and so the
other the other reason we're
particularly excited about the effect in
boys is that to the extent anything has
worked in this age group it's only ever
worked for girls nothing works with boys
this second reason by the way that this
might just not not have quite as much
motivational juice with girls is that
the notion of sticking it to the man I
think is a little bit gendered we
realized after the fact and and and so
that might have been that might have
made it resonate slightly less with the
girls bottom line here is that values
this is an instance of what I'm calling
values on line there and I'll remind you
the idea here is to frame appeals in
terms of how they serve
of existing widely shared important
values right so adolescents by making
healthy choices now don't need to think
I'm doing what my teacher says I should
be doing so that I'll be healthy in ten
years which I don't care about instead
they get to think oh yeah I'm being I'm
being a like a super in the no teenager
and doing all these things that are very
I don't know I know I sound like a super
cool teenager right now and doing a
great impression super in the no
teenager and I'm being a good teenager
and my peers will approve of me is the
bottom line
and I think this may be a powerful means
to change how I change people's behavior
across a wide range of domains and in a
wide range of age groups now I started
with this example of adolescents it
would be totally reasonable to say well
okay sure but like adolescents and
rebellion is maybe like the single best
example of a value that that sort of
drives a group of people really
powerfully so would this work well in
other groups I'm going to tell you about
some in progress research to give you a
sense of what this sort of approach
might look like in an adult population
what we focused on in that work was
trying to motivate regular small
charitable donations right so there's
enormous benefit that could come from
getting people a large percentage of the
population who can afford it to make
small regular charitable donations I
think the major reason why that doesn't
happen is that the thing that drives us
to make charitable donation as much as
we'd like to say it's the benefit it has
to the people we're giving to it's the
feeling of having done something good
that drives charitable donation I think
to a large extent and that ten dollars
that most people can afford to give to a
charitable organization once a month
just doesn't feel big enough to be
significant and so the alternative
approach that we are experimenting with
is it focuses on parents in particular
and it was driven by or this idea came
out of an experience I had walking out
of a supermarket with my son on
Thanksgiving one year
I was walking out of Vaughn's
supermarket in San Diego and
Thanksgiving Day in the Salvation Army
guys were out and ringing their bells
and rather than just walk by as I'm
embarrassed to admit I usually do I
thought oh this is a great opportunity I
took my son aside and I said Henry okay
you know how we're about to go and have
this like amazing dinner and enjoy it
with our friends and family and he was
like yeah I was like well lots of people
can't afford to do that and so I want
you to take this money and go give it to
that person put in that bucket over
there and then they're gonna help some
of those families who don't have enough
money to be able to do things like that
and he did and just the emotional bang I
got for that was just so much greater
than the emotional bang it would have
gotten from dropping two bucks in The
Salvation Army bucket by myself and so I
thought well this this actually might
have potential for from many if not most
middle-class parents I think most of us
walk around sort of low-key worried were
raising selfish [ __ ] like I
definitely do I worry about that all the
time and communicating values like this
is not it's not obvious how you do it
right how do you get your kid to care
about other people and so I thought well
what if we frame regular charitable
giving as a teachable moment as a
parenting opportunity you incorporate
your child into this giving process and
by example you're showing them it's
important to care about other people and
so we've done a series now of
sort of laboratory type studies where
we're sort of testing out these ideas
before we do the big study you really
want to see and in all of those
laboratory studies we're getting pretty
encouraging findings so if we get people
like at the Children's Museum when we
take them aside if we get them to think
about making a charitable donation with
their child rather than just
entertaining their child for them while
they do it
they are more excited about giving and
more willing to have their email address
given to a food bank to be solicited for
future donations the study we're doing
now is with chimp which is a large
Canadian charitable donation hub so you
can give to any
registered Canadian charity through
chimp you set up an account they
specifically encourage regular small
donation and so it's sort of ideally set
up for this and what we're experimenting
with is starting hopefully within a week
or two when people land on this site
they will get one of the following three
appeals but this is the one I'm excited
about it's the it's the charitable
allowance version right so teaching your
child to be a kind person can be easy
set up a charitable allowance and watch
them learn your values right the idea is
you give your kid whatever amount you
think is reasonable every week you spend
time that and being a parent I know you
need to set this up so that it doesn't
require extra time in your week and so
we say like during drives or over meals
whatever whenever time you have spare
time to chat talk about what might be
some good organizations to give to give
to and then once a month sit down and
give that money out right and so the
idea is now the the reason for giving
isn't the benefit it has to the
organizations are giving to the the sort
of direct reason in people's minds the
reason for giving is it's solving this
pretty pretty important parenting goal
this pretty important parenting problem
for people and the side effect is that
it has this charitable benefit we're
comparing that to the individual version
of course so making kindness a part of
your life can be easy set up a regular
giving account to live in a way that
expresses your values and then to make
sure that this isn't just about giving
with a person you love we're comparing
it to a partner giving group so where
you set this up with your romantic
partner and and you share the values
together and so our expectation is the
charitable allowance in particular will
be effective at getting people to
register and getting them to keep on
giving because it's addressing this
existing important need okay so those
are sort of the core the core findings I
wanted to talk about in the core ideas
you want I wanted to talk about I think
sort of if I if I want to leave you with
sort of a bottom line point from this
talk I think it's that
there's been too much focus on getting
people to do the right thing for what
experts think is the right reason right
what experts think is the right reason
is highly relevant to policy discussions
it may not be as relevant to the
motivational question the question of
what will get people to actually change
their behavior in fact if the pragmatic
reasons were important to the most
people then we wouldn't need to appeal
to them to change their behavior the
pragmatic case is very strong for
engaging in should behavior and then
related to this I think there's just a
little too much focused on material
self-interest as the primary motivator
of people there's no question it's an
important motivator but I think there
are situations and in particular
situations in which a behavior a
sacrifice in the immediate term is
required in service of some distant
pragmatic benefit where a material
self-interest really doesn't work very
well for people just it's not
well-suited to the way our brains work
and so in those situations rather than
trying to force it rather than yelling
at people that they really should care
about their futures we can explore
alternative ways of motivating this sort
of behavior right we can find
alternative values that might be served
by these behaviors that we're trying to
encourage and appeal to people on those
grounds and in doing that actually
actually get traction and move the
needle a little bit thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you my first question I have in
we're gonna be taking questions from the
audience as well but I I wanted to ask
kind of chicken-or-egg question with the
way you do these studies do you the one
that the example you brought up with the
Salvation Army with your kid you kind of
figured out a hack and then applied it
or was that also the case of the dietary
studies or were you look at do you also
go we have this problem how do we figure
out the values that we need to associate
with okay the honest answer is usually
it's the former usually it's oh man that
worked on me I wonder if we work on
other people or if there's a version
that would work on other people the
healthy eating one was kind of an
interesting hybrid and I've been moving
more towards the latter which is here's
a problem what are some good solutions
the healthy eating one was actually born
out of a consulting project I'm thinking
carefully about what will violate my NDA
and what won't but I'm gonna play play
it safe here and say the goal is to get
families to adopt healthy habits we had
I happen to be reading a book about the
food industry at the time and so I
started coming up with all these ideas
that were super anti corporate and this
was a consulting project for a fortune
100 company so they were like no we
can't do that man we have partners
partnerships with a lot of these
companies and so we just got like made a
file of ideas this was me and my one of
my primary collaborators a developmental
psychologist named David Yeager at UT
Austin in this case we made a file of
ideas that didn't work for that
consulting project and pitched them as a
grant proposal and that's that's what
yeah yeah nice and that was that
federally funded I know no it wasn't
interesting and that brings me to my
next question which is and I'm sure you
get this a lot and are and think about
it a lot is this this also seems like a
gun you can get turned on yourself
pretty easily and that this same
technique I mean effectively this is how
you know
ideas about vaccinations or something
like that gets spread by articles that
are shown to people as science right and
make them feel like they're aligning
with a certain set of people yeah so we
see this happening in the world today
for for nefarious reasons I'm wondering
how that aligns with your work and how
about how worried you are that they're
gonna use this kind of work with kids
against them yeah so let me think a
couple of they're a bunch of answers to
that so one is we made very sure that
everything we said in the healthy eating
informational articles was true so it's
all based on journalistic accounts that
are sort of solid and vetted in in part
for ethical reasons and in part because
we recognize that it would create this
enormous opera we'd be enormous
hypocrites if we said like these guys
are manipulating you and we were
manipulating them and so we I mean there
are people definitely who would say
we're manipulative who would still say
we're manipulating them the way I feel
comfortable with it is by making sure
it's all true so by making sure that
we're giving them good information that
I in good faith believe is an accurate
representation of the big picture and we
frame it as such we say like this is
stuff we don't think you're being told
like you're told other stuff we think
you're not told this and so we're gonna
tell you this but there was more to your
question no I mean I think that's a the
key there is you know is working with
the truth and also I mean obviously
truth is really up quite a bit these
days but I think it's right so that's
the real question but and and you're I'm
not expecting you to solve that
particular problem no that's a hard
problem I do think I do think the
vaccination thing is a different issue
and I still don't know my head around
that issue so but but I just mostly the
reason I said that is just I think
that's a little bit different it's it
goes beyond the lining with that that's
that's really tapping into I think what
is doing is tapping into like the
combination combination of like risk
aversion
and fear right so it's like there's
actually a huge component that is
sticking it to the man part of that like
yeah I see what you're saying yeah yeah
skills for the format totally right yeah
even vaccinations yeah yeah there's a
similar thing but it's with adults
generally right and I'm a problem that
we we run up against a lot here long now
is this discounting of the future and
I'm wondering if you if you don't that
at a deep level to do why do we do this
what is what is the evolutionary reason
that that we don't that we don't value
the future so with the with the like
stipulate the important proviso that
like armchair evolutionary theorizing is
there's there may be is no thing that is
more disdained by academics and so like
please don't show this part other
academics but it seems it seems like
that there's a straightforward answer
here which is just like you don't need
to think about the long term to get to
the like procreation point right and
that's the main driver of evolution so
yeah great do we have some questions in
the back there thank you so my question
is in the context of climate change most
of what you've brought up is are
examples of changing individuals
behavior for their benefit climate
change is something that it's a
collective problem yeah and the question
this is sort of a is it the individual
behavior we need to change where the
system's behavior we need to change
question but there's been a lot of
emphasis on individual behavior change
yeah towards climate so giving your
research and give them both of these
things is it the behavior of the system
or the behavior the individual we need
and then what we've used so far to
motivate people to change their
individual behavior what comments do you
have about what's wrong about the
evolved strategies about getting things
to work and using our behavior change
theories which also seem to be more
focused on short term behavior change
rather than long term well yeah all
right
I have like 15 thoughts about that so
I'll probably forget some but I'll try
to get the best ones out before that I
have
so it's happening already hold on hold
on it's coming so the first thing he
said was oh yeah okay so the the system
versus individual that's not unique to
climate change so like that's also the
perspective and public health broadly
right so like the one of the common
answers I get to this work I talked
about is like what we need to do is
change the system and that's certainly
true the problem is that there I don't
know how to fix that problem right
because that that that that's like there
are enormous political barriers to
changing the system and so I think the
answer is we need both and the changing
individuals gets a whole lot easier if
you change the system but I know how to
try to change people's individual
people's behavior so that's the part I'm
working on climate change I think is the
one area of sort of behavior change
appeals that is the most ahead of the
curve on this so I think people started
figuring out like at least 10 maybe 15
years ago that talking about climate
change wasn't gonna get traction with a
lot of people but other values would
like energy independence or for
religious Christians the notion of
stewardship which is important in the
Bible and so that's the only area of
policy where sort of the current
approach I think most closely
approximates what I would say is the
right approach beyond that there's like
an art to it to like seeing it just the
right way I feel like they're not always
great at that but that that's a pretty
minor critique the single worst instance
of behavior change by the way that I'm
aware of
it's since we're in San Francisco KQED
they are so bad at doing their appeals
for donation like if you would too if
you to make a list of like the top 5
things to not do they do all of them
unbelievable they constantly communicate
the wrong descriptive norm they're
always saying if most people would give
we'd be off we'd be off the air in no
time but unfortunately nobody gives you
know it you know what people's reaction
to that is okay cool I'm off the hook
it's humble anyway yeah sorry that was a
rant just just coming out of the winter
pledge drive yeah but like other NPR
stations are better at this like I've
lived it I've since lived I used to live
in the bag I went to graduate school at
Stanford so I lived in the Bay Area for
a long while and then in San Diego and
Chicago KPBS KQED KQED that's the what
did I say Kay cuties here what is it
WBEZ in Chicago both way better at this
I don't know why KQED is so bad at it
they have some of the best psychologists
in the world like right down the road
nice somebody else isn't like so you've
been talking about fairly what happens
okay so I was talking about adolescents
who are malleable in the sense that
they're adaptable they I wouldn't say
that that most parents would think of
them as malleable in the sense that they
listen to it adults say but I still take
your point they're adaptable in terms of
how they think about the reasons for
their behavior they're open to trying
new types of new ways of being so I
don't think this depends on that I think
that sort of like the parenting studies
are a case of an older group that's
that's sort of responsive to this sort
of approach I think that the big
challenge the sort of big relative
challenge among an older population
compared with adolescents I guess that I
can think of is habit and the the
challenge of overcoming habit but that
doesn't strike me as insurmountable I
think like if you find the right value
and it and it's got enough motivational
juice how habits aren't that hard to
overcome
Heather Oh
so I wonder with oh that struggles a lot
with the change yeah so that's a an
excellent question and I actually think
it's broader even than than the way
you're framing it I think that the
general risk that if you give people a
compelling appeal to change their
behavior and they fail that that might
have negative effects is is is probably
a pretty broad thing to want to think
about one thing and actually unhealthy
food is a pretty good case of an
addiction is it's a it's kind of a
complicated one right because we we're
not supposed to stop eating food but but
it but yeah and so there are a bunch of
sort of psychological approaches that we
incorporate into these interventions to
try to have to try to avoid that kind of
pitfall and related pitfalls for example
we needed to be very careful that we
weren't like shaming overweight kids
when we were doing this so we like bent
over backwards to make sure this wasn't
about what you look like this is about
well two things it's about what you eat
and it's not and and no one's saying
people who eat junk food are bad people
what we were saying was these companies
are trying to trick you and so that also
sort of takes some of the takes some of
the potential for shame out of it
we found in related work in that
consulting project that it was actually
it actually made the overweight kids
happier not not less happy so this was
in the context of a theme park and so
like they made healthier choices and had
a better time so I think like
it's I take that as as reassurance that
it's certainly possible to do this sort
of thing
without without creating the sort of
negative side effects that that you're
alluding to
I briefly mentioned there are psychology
collage achill approaches without
telling you what they were so one big
one I think is just the notion of growth
mindset which has been widely
popularized it's this idea by by Carol
Dweck a psychologist at Stanford who's
been an advisor of mine and in a major
influence that just believing things are
tangible that you can improve is
extraordinarily powerful in part because
it changes your interpretation of
struggle so instead of being a signal
that you're not capable of this if you
believe that you have a fixed ability at
something and then you struggle then the
natural and the natural conclusion is my
difficulty is diagnosing me as not not
measuring up on this but if you believe
that that people can improve then
instead the the common conclusion is
this is an opportunity for me to get
better at something and so I think I've
done this a bunch and interventions
combining growth mindset with other
forms of psychology specifically with
this sort of concern you mentioned in
mind oh I don't yeah up here in the
front row okay well back there and then
I'll come up front so I do make sure
that I don't know that I would go be
quite so blanket in that but yes often
doesn't yeah yeah with all the like
things academics a to not be to be sure
they never say anything wrong yeah
and one particular instantiation of this
a spectrum for teenagers is this framing
of sticking it to the man
yeah now you yourself healthy but to me
this gets back to the shooting yourself
with your own two feet
yeah because it's divorced from
pragmatics and because other people are
not obligated to follow the same ethical
guidelines that you yourself followed
you can apply us to other things we have
change well scientists say the
scientists are trying to trick you yeah
sticking it to the man is believing this
other thing they don't want you to
believe
same thing with vaccines and you know
the part that I'm confused about is I
think chorus issues since its divorce
from pragmatics why isn't this just
technique yeah okay it is just a
technique for convincing people it is
it's just a technique for convincing
people the bad guys already know about
it they've been doing it for a long time
the people who need this lesson are the
public health workers and the the
earnest policy wonks who think man if we
could just get people to listen and so
right now so yeah you're right so the
one version of of the message from my
talk is like now we can like get
everyone to do healthy stuff all the
time I think a more realistic version is
this is an attempt to even the playing
field a little bit
right so like junk food marketing has
been using I mean it's funny they
sometimes hit on these brilliant
approaches and then like go back to a
stupid approach so I don't think they
have very good theory behind what
they're doing but they have a lot of
creative genius behind what they're
doing and so you do get this every now
and then and same thing with
I'm trying to member well people who
want to destroy the climate was that the
yeah but I mean like the beef Lobby they
I mean I I don't want to like whatever
but but I I was at some meeting about
like how can we get people to make
healthy healthy choices and and it
wasn't like a situation like this where
I could just get to stand up and expound
about my personal view on it for 30
minutes or whatever it was just me and a
bunch of other people who also thought
they were the world's leading expert in
it and so like if I you know and so I
didn't get as much time air time to talk
and so like but I just pointed out like
the do with the beef Lobby does like
identify a core American value and then
tie yourself to that right so it's like
beef its what for dinner that's the
that's the point of that right the point
is like that's what Americans eat for
you a real American right and so like
this isn't a new idea it's really me
putting pointing at this approach and
saying this can be used also to
encourage healthy behavior it doesn't
only persuade people to do bad bad stuff
how do we make bread X actually work
yeah you can twist it because as as
Xander just pointed out I mean truth is
a really slippery subject these days I I
don't think they're I don't think
there's an escape from from like
propaganda I think the best we can do is
get good at it and adhere to a value
system in how we use it I don't need
enough money I just beat the crap out of
coca-cola with one one hundred
thousandth of their budget an annual
budget that's her and our budget was
over four years
I'm curious also and we'll get them a
good friend and about you you've one of
the things that the kids wrote was about
I don't know was a jay-z wanted to drink
sorry I'm already not cool
the Drake does it and so I wondered have
you researched the the role model thing
I was always amazed with my daughter
that if I got if someone two years older
than her said something yeah it was the
Word of God oh yeah but if I said
something it was like I was furniture
talking totally and so there's I think
there there is this amazing kind of
capability for kids to look up to
certain people yes in the exact right
circumstances and and as I look back on
my own childhood the many lessons that I
learned from my parents were we're
probably much more done by modeling and
not by them telling me anything yeah but
things that certain peers told me stuck
in my head forever so I'm just wondering
how that fits into this research the
peer thing the older peer thing is
actually just standard it's a standard
technique included in adolescent
interventions like this now so you give
a survey to a bunch of kids who are two
years older and you get and then and
then you get to a place where you can
say like most kids in the ninth grade
survey said that they thought this was a
great idea
and it on its own it's not likely to
create lasting change well I don't think
we know that for sure my sense is that
on its own it's not but it's really
valuable really powerful supporting
psychology yeah so it gives it gives I
think like one thing you face when you
do an intervention with teenagers is you
have to pass the test of like are you
legit or not and this is one of the
things that can help you pass that test
you have to start by being cool I mean
no that's not a goal you should aspire
to it's not gonna happen but I mean I'm
nor nor should I right but I'm saying
like you can you can rely on the
coolness of ninth graders yeah
oh yeah
[Music]
[Music]
you know - sorry I teach them what so
when you're talking about neutral you're
talking about the huh that right sure
yeah so teaching kids to be skeptical
and and research their choices yeah so
you're yes okay so I'm trying to like
boil your your comment no no just to
make sure I understand it I'm trying to
I think if I were if are gonna try to
encapsulate it would be something like
this is this is all fine and good but
you and I know you were being way more
polite than that this is all fine and
good but you're still not really making
the media literate you're giving them
your message and emphasizing things you
think are important yeah we're
politically literate and you mean
political like very broadly construed to
me and like whatever my career is the
good is what she means
no but you you mean that that this is
informed by my conception of the good
right yeah yeah yeah Wow
i I don't know if I
good answer to that I think the reason I
don't grapple with it is that it's too
big right like I don't know I think I
would be paralyzed if I try so it
wouldn't be effective I don't think to
just make them media literate because
you need to give them a reason to care
about it and their reasons I'm gonna
come up with are gonna be informed by my
conception of the good I think it's
unavoidable I think all of us have our
sort of private conception of the good
and I agree that at some point people
should understand that and appreciate
that everything anyone ever says is
going to be informed by that but I'm
trying to avoid a cliche here and say
not allowing the perfect to become the
enemy of the good but that's really the
substance of my answer I think yeah
[Music]
everything yeah
but it's not is it's yeah and but taking
a little bit of one less two questions
raised to its like how about you know
it's good it's cool to care about your
own health mm-hmm right
I mean sure it's cool to like right yeah
like yeah back to your plan yeah yeah
like it's punk rock to care yeah yeah
actually I am not ready to say that I
don't think that has a lot of potential
I kind of love that I'm gonna think more
about it I kind of love that and we're
gonna wrap up here and you're gonna hang
out and ask some more questions
afterwards but the is the last question
I have to ask you is what's what's your
next project what what do you what do
you want to attack with this technique
next or or I'll give you a choice yeah
if you could do anything and you got the
grant for it what would it be I'm not
gonna do the anything one right now what
I'm trying to do is just figure out I
figure out just how broad the potential
is for this idea
so I'm trying it in a wide range of
contexts I'm trying to refine the theory
and make sure that I understand why it's
happening so one thing I didn't I didn't
have time to put in here that we
discovered about the adolescent
intervention is that it works best for
the boys who are highest in testosterone
which is an indication of being more
pubertal II advanced and testosterone is
is largely misunderstood so people think
of it as driving aggression there would
it would it essentially drives is the is
is reward like we want reward and in
particular social reward and it surges
in adolescence specifically because we
need to be driven to pursue social
reward in order to figure out how to be
good social agents and so what we found
was that the boys who are highest in
testosterone showed the biggest
reductions in junk food consumption as a
result of this intervention which is
actually a really remarkable finding
when you think about it for a second it
drys reward sensitivity responsiveness
to reward and junk food is super
rewarding so in the control condition
testosterone is correlated with higher
junk food consumption and so what this
is doing is it's not just picking off
the people who were who had the least
problematic behavior it's actually
taking the behavior of the kids who had
the most problematic behaved
year and it's telling us something about
the process by which this works at the
same time and and that is its it
suggests that what we have done in fact
is successfully change what kids think
of as rewarding which is what I briefly
mentioned it's this like substituting
the distant pragmatic reward with an
immediate symbolic reward this is
supportive of that and so that's
exciting
that was a super tangent that didn't
answer your question but I mentioned it
just because every time we tried any new
context we learn something new and cool
about the theory so another thing I've
been working on is getting parents in
Uganda to give their kids micronutrient
powder so there's an organization called
brac they're actually the largest
development NGO in the world and
nobody's really heard of them which is I
never had and they're based in
Bangladesh originally and they have this
model where they send community health
promoters out into communities and have
them bring prophylactic health products
to your door so there's an earlier paper
by some guys at the innovations for
poverty action an academic organization
based at Northwestern showing that that
significantly increases uptake of
prophylactic health products so like we
have this stereotype that that a
Theriault type of psychology that like
little inconveniences shouldn't matter
that much but this is a great
demonstration that that's simply not
true right so these are people who
desperately need these products and they
by way more of them if someone comes to
their door and part of the reason is if
you're poor you don't just not have
money you also don't have time and so
man I'm very susceptible to tangents I
apologize point is now they're now brac
is introducing this micronutrient powder
which is super important because it
prevents stunting so even if kids get
enough calories they may not get enough
of the micronutrients that their brains
and bodies need to grow to fully develop
and after age 5 the likelihood that you
can ever overcome that deficit gets
lower and lower so they're trying to
catch kids with parents early enough
trying to catch parents with kids young
enough and then get them to buy these at
a sub
today's rate at the lowest price they
can afford to offer them and they need
to explain why they're important and so
we're testing an approach that is values
aligned but that substantive
substantively isn't different from the
from the comparison condition so the
comparison condition is the default
approach it's it's what they were gonna
do without us and it's like they were
going to use the picture the picture on
the box is a picture of a little cartoon
tiger eating porridge and it says for
your child's healthy growth and that
makes a certain amount of sense when you
realize that these are made in India and
in South Asia Tigers or mythical
creatures not so in East Africa so the
first reaction that parents had was like
is this cat food and then the second
reaction they had was like look at him
he's healthy he's running around what
are you talking about and so you need to
explain so I had this whole like
qualitative process with parents where I
tried to understand like what are your
dreams for your child's future and how
do you think about the relationship
between what you feed them and and and
and those dreams and that sort of thing
and we ended up with an alternative that
substantively is the same but it's got
an image of a young couple with a baby
and then the same couple aged with you
know makeup and stuff standing next to a
fully grown young man or young woman in
graduation garb and the slogan is
stronger a brain stronger body stronger
future because the the thing that
parents talk about more than really
anything is hoping their kid becomes a
successful professional like parents in
in in the parts of East Africa that I
visited are willing to endure
unbelievable hardship to make sure their
kids stay in school for example it's not
there's no problem a lack of commitment
to their kids futures but the existing
approach just didn't connect it to that
strong Drive so anyway that's that's
that's one future slash ongoing project
and very cool well I along with
everybody here hope you don't get hired
by the ad agencies and that's not how
they do it I want to thank you with
whatever challenge points thank you
[Applause]
[Music]